a educação é o único caminho para que o
brasil se torne o país que queremos
quando a gente analisa 76 países o
brasil ocupa o 60º lugar no ranking
mundial de educação
comparando os 61 países nó em 56º lugar
em competitividade
quando a gente olha para os alunos
brasileiros de escolas públicas
apenas 23 dentro desses alunos têm a
competência que precisamos de leitura
interpretação de texto
esse número é de apenas 11% na resolução
de problemas
o movimento mapa educação é uma
iniciativa de jovens brasileiros que se
uniram com o objetivo de aproximar a
sociedade civil do debate educacional
pra que a gente possa juntos lutar por
uma educação de qualidade no nosso país
a trajetória do mapa é muito próxima da
minha trajetória
eu venho de uma família humilde meu pai
não chegou a terminar o ensino
fundamental
a minha mãe só terminou o ensino médio
há poucos anos
no entanto ele te forçaram muito pra que
eu e meu irmão pudéssemos estudar e dar
o melhor de nós nos estudos
por muito tempo eu queria trabalhar com
artesanatos até a 5ª série eu estudei em
escolas públicas e bordava e pintava
para ajudar minha família em casa
no entanto na quinta série participei da
primeira olimpíada brasileira de
matemática das escolas públicas obmep
a obmep foi a primeira grande
oportunidade que eu tive na minha de
realmente ver que grande políticas
públicas simples poderiam ter um impacto
enorme na vida de milhões de pessoas ao
ser premiada anac na 5ª série e na 6ª
série na primeira e na segunda e mep
recebi uma bolsa de estudos em uma
escola privada incrível de são paulo
eu moro na periferia
na zona sul a escola fica no centro e
foi aí que eu percebi como o nosso país
é marcado por enormes desigualdades dois
mundos completamente diferentes
estavam ali uma hora e vinte de
distâncias de ônibus e metrô
chegando no colégio fiquei maravilhada
era tudo muito diferente
estudei bastante consegui me destacar na
minha sala
mas chegando no final do ano fui
convidada para uma cerimônia para todos
os alunos do colégio que tinham feito
olimpíadas e sido premiados
eu não ter feito nenhuma olimpíada mas
que fui convidado assim mesmo
chegando lá eles tinham uma camiseta bem
simples e preta que davam pra todos os
anos que tinham sido premiados
eu não ganhei a camiseta e fiquei muito
triste por mais que pareça bobeira eu
comecei a pensar tudo bem
tive uma oportunidade incrível que todos
os meus amigos que ficaram na escola
pública não tiveram cheguei aqui estudei
mas que eu fiz em especial eu não fiz
nada além
eu fiquei naquela mesmice das aulas e
não fez tudo o que estava ao meu alcance
como sou de chorar chorei bastante e meu
pai que estava comigo na cerimônia vendo
aquilo começou a conversar comigo e foi
então que eu prometi meu pai no ano
seguinte vou em a camiseta sai parece
pouco mas realmente me incentivou e não
foi a única promessa que eu fiz no dia
durante essa mesma cerimônia foi uma
moça do emitir e ela falou pra gente
alunos brasileiros podem estudar em
escolas incríveis americanas e ela
mostrou um vídeo super bacana que tinha
um clube de chocolate um clube de sol
sorvete eu não falava inglês e entende
nada
mas fiquei com os olhos brilhando e
falei pro meu pai quer saber
vou estudar numa universidade americana
um dia não sei quem era mais doido
eu que fazia um montão de promessas sem
pé nem cabeça o meu pai que falava 'você
vai sim alcançar tudo isso no ano
seguinte estudei muito tinha que ganhar
a camiseta e pode ser feito nas
olimpíadas na 8ª série ganhou oito
medalhas e fui super confiante
chegando na cerimônia adquirir um novo
sonho eu vi que alunos brasileiros
podiam representar o brasil em
competições internacionais
ciências então foi que eu decidi um dia
eu vou representar o meu país em uma
competição internacional
estudei bastante e no segundo ano foi
pra minha primeira competição na china
foi a primeira vez que eu saí do brasil
eu representei o nosso país na 4ª
olimpíada internacional de astronomia e
astrofísica
foi incrível fiz amigos de todos os
países e realmente decidi que eu tinha
que estudar nos estados unidos pra ter
essa experiência internacional
no entanto algumas coisas começaram a
ficar mais difíceis em casa
meu pai sempre teve muitos problemas com
vícios e isso foi piorando e ele também
desenvolveu algumas doenças psicológicas
então a situação financeira que já não
era muito boa começou a complicar ea
gente não tinha mais como pagar pela
alimentação pelo transporte para ir à
escola e aí eu fui me afastando de
algumas atividades do colégio mas de
novo alguém acreditou em mim
dessa vez não foi meu pai foi um
professor o professor rubens ele viu que
estava me afastando das atividades
conversou com a diretoria e no dia
seguinte ficou decidido entre os
diretores da minha escola minha mãe que
eu ia morar no hotel
por mais que pareça incrível eu moraria
no hotel a cinco minutos do colégio
teria minha alimentação e transporte
pagos
eu fiquei muito triste porque minha
família está passando por um momento
muito difícil eu estava simplesmente
abandonando a minha família mas enfim
foi pro hotel e pra aguentar firme
decidi que faria duas coisas primeiro me
dedicar ainda mais nos meus estudos e
segundo projeto voa voa significa
vontade única de aprender antes do
ensino médio eu havia confundido esse
projeto com os amigos e todos os finais
de semana preparamos os alunos de
escolas públicas para olimpíadas de
ciências
eu acho que o golo surgiu de uma
percepção muito grande que eu estava
tendo oportunidades incríveis mas que
isso não era verdade para a maioria dos
brasileiros
então eu tinha que fazer alguma coisa
porque eu fui escolhida para ter sertão
abençoada tem que fazer alguma coisa
sobre isso bem continua estudando
bastante e no terceiro ano do ensino
médio conseguir representar
o brasil e outras quatro olimpíadas
internacionais conhecia a polônia
conhecia turquia e multipliquei meu
sonho de representar o nosso país por
cinco
foi uma época muito difícil e muito
incrível também tinha que fazer
vestibular americano tinha que fazer o
vestibular brasileiro tinham as
olimpíadas e muitas vezes eu queria
desistir
realmente estava muito medo de tudo isso
mas de uma coisa tinham muitas pessoas
lutando por aqueles sonhos comigo já não
era mais o sonho da tabela de ir para os
estados unidos
era o sonho dos professores sonho da
minha família era o sonho dos meus
amigos então continuem e no ano seguinte
foi aprovada em física na usp
comecei a trabalhar de química e
astronomia e comecei a cursar faculdade
e no dia 8 de março de 2012
recebi a melhor notícia da minha vida
foi aceita na universidade harvard com
100% de bolsa
eu não consigo nem expressar o como eu
me senti feliz naquele dia era a
realização de mais de cinco anos e bem
fiquei superfeliz e liguei para os meus
pais e eles tiveram duas razões que me
marcaram muito porque representa muito
como eles eram minha mãe atende o
telefone disse já comeu se vai passar
mal não
meu deus super preocupada comigo meu pai
tranquila do jeito dele olha eu sempre
disse que você é passar você deveria me
escutar mais como ficar tão estressada
então aquele dia foi bem marcante pra
mim só que passaram se quatro dias e aí
eu recebi a pior notícia da minha vida
todos os vícios que haviam feito e por
tanto tempo do ele e aí eu acho que quem
já perdeu alguém da família entende que
tudo desse tipo sentido a universidade
americana os meus sonhos os meus estudos
e foi então que eu saí da faculdade
porque minha mãe tinha ficado
desempregado então comecei a trabalhar
mais e desistir aquela história de que
os estados unidos que isso sabe não faz
mais sentido e bem
passou-se um tempo e no mês eu tinha que
dar resultado a decisão pelas
universidades se eu iria ou não eu
estava decidida que não mas outra vez
uma pessoa importante na minha vida a
silvinha que era da minha escola falou
'você não vai fazer isso comprar uma
passagem para ir para os estados unidos
as peças e falou neste final de semana
você vai e você vai entender o tamanho
da tua decisão e chegando lá você falar
aqui bem mas não vai desistir tão fácil
não foi às praias visitadas seis
universidades no final tinha sido aceito
em 6 com bolsa completa
chegando lá fiquei maravilhada era tudo
tão incrível e as oportunidades que eu
teria tão maravilhosas como dizer não
por aquilo e aí eu percebi que indo pra
lá seria minha maneira de mudar a
educação do meu país seria minha maneira
de mudar a vida da minha família então
eu decidi que sim que eu iria para os
estados unidos
ele escolheu a universidade harvard e no
dia 1º de maio de 2012
mandei a minha decisão desde então
muitas coisas aconteceram tem estudado
bastante trabalhei ainda mais
comecei a estudar nossa profissão que eu
porque eu queria ser cientista
depois mudei para ciências políticas
astrofísica ver o meu curso secundário
visitei e conheci muitos países já fiz
montão de coisas e nesse tempo eu
descobri o meu sonho grande e o meu
sonho grande é que um dia o brasil tenha
a melhor educação pública do mundo e é
isso mesmo é uma das melhores não é a
melhor
e aí eu tinha um sonho grande mas o que
você faz com ele conversando com um
grande momento
vargas eu falei olha que era uma da
educação do brasil mas que eu faço e ele
me deu duas dicas muito boas
a primeira que todo mundo que ele tinha
visto tendo um impacto muito bacana não
tinha esperado de 40 50 anos tinha
começado muito cedo quando você acha que
não consegue fazer nada então ele falou
você vai começar antes de sair de árvore
a segunda coisa é que toda boa ideia
tinha um time ainda melhor por trás
então ele falou mesmo que você não saiba
o que fará exatamente contra seu time
que as idéias vão surgir e aí eu
convidei dois grandes amigos ali
o renan e falei ao pessoal a gente tem
que mudar a educação do brasil vão fazer
alguma coisa ea gente falou então tudo
bem
não somos especialistas da educação
vamos fazer uma pesquisa
vamos estudar e ver o que a gente pode
fazer como quente vai convencer essa
juventude toda a lutar pela educação
entendem a importância da educação
primeiro fizemos uma pesquisa
entrevistamos mais de 100 pessoas
estudamos diversos documentos por meses
para a gente entender qual é o cenário
da educação no brasil e o que deveria
ser feito bem essa pesquisa ficou tão
grande que ando manifesto e no ano
passado lançamos o manifesto mapa do
buraco apontando os principais problemas
da educação no brasil e o que alguns
lugares estavam fazendo que estava dando
certo como era época de eleições
lançamos o desafio mapa do buraco
nele a gente convidava candidatos do
brasil inteiro a responderem através de
um vídeo se você for eleito o que fará
pela educação do brasil
esses candidatos mandaram os vídeos
desafiando no final três outras pessoas
a fazerem o mesmo
também realizamos em parceria com a voz
do brasil e com fgv
o único debate que houve entre a dilma
eo oeste sobre educação
a gente sabe que educação não decidiu as
eleições e que cada vez mais abandonada
no nosso país
então a gente vai mudar de nome ao invés
de ser o mapa do buraco viramos um
movimento mapa educação o objetivo com o
mesmo engajar a sociedade civil engajar
o jovem para lutar por uma educação de
maior qualidade
hoje o movimento à educação o mapa tem
três objetivos o primeiro é engaja e
informar as pessoas através das redes
sociais
então diariamente nossa página do
facebook divulgamos notícias sobre
educação resumo de artigos pegamos leis
estão sendo votados em brasília que
afetam a educação colocamos no nosso
público votar na página do facebook pra
realmente o pessoal entenda a nossa
educação não tá bem ea única coisa que a
gente pode fazer com segurança para
garantir um futuro melhor para o país
o segundo objetivo era criar uma rede de
pessoas com idéias e projetos para mudar
nossa educação que pudessem se conectar
entre si e com outras pessoas
lançamos o desafio mapa educação e
recebemos 170 inscrições de jovens do
brasil inteiro que tinham idéias
maravilhosas
selecionamos os 100 projetos com maior
impacto e no dia 29 de agosto de 2015
teremos a primeira conferência má
educação reunindo esses 100 jovens do
brasil inteiro com empresários com o
ministério e com as fundações que
realmente fazem educação acontecer
um dos objetivos mais importantes do
mapa e o terceiro é escutar a voz do
jovem e saber o que o jovem pensa sobre
educação o que funciona o que o motiva o
que era o que desmotiva
por isso estamos com a pesquisa online
para realmente escutar a voz do jovem e
podemos ficar lá
hoje o mapa conta com mais de 40
coordenadores e tem apoiadores pelo
brasil e pelo mundo inteiro
o nosso objetivo é o mesmo e eu acho que
tudo o que eu aprendi com o mapa e com a
minha trajetória me mostraram que
realmente a educação é a arma mais
poderosa que como dizia nelson mandela e
lembra aquele dia eu fui pra segunda
cerimônia dos medalhistas com as minhas
oito medalhas toda feliz lá eu descobri
que naquele ano
você não precisava de uma medalha pra
mim a camiseta ou seja se não tivesse
feito as olimpíadas teria ganhado a
camiseta igual
e foi então que descobri que muitas
vezes o caminho que você é muito mais
importante do que onde você chega e é
por isso que eu realmente acredito que a
educação é o único caminho para que o
brasil se torne o país que a gente quer
essa é a única maneira da gente
completou das desigualdades que temos
pelo brasil afora para que todo
brasileiro independente de quem seja e
de onde more i tem uma educação de
qualidade
muito obrigada